PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
We've all experienced
the benefits of crowdsourcing.
Whether it's
restaurant reviews that
help us find a perfect place
for dinner or crowdfunding
to bring our favorite
TV show back to life,
these distributed
contributions combined
to make some super useful tools.
What if we use that
same concept to build
better machine learning models?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and on this episode,
we are going to examine a
different approach to machine
learning.
Standard machine
learning approaches
require centralizing
the training data
into a common store.
So let's say we want to train a
keyboard prediction model based
on user interactions.
Traditionally, we
implemented intelligence
by collecting all the data on
the server, create a model,
and then serve it.
Clients all talk to the
server to make prediction.
The model and the data is
all in one central location,
making it extremely easy.
But the downside of
this centralized setup
is that this back-and-forth
communication
can hurt the user
experience due to network
latency, connectivity,
battery lives, and all sorts
of unpredictable issues.
One way to solve this is to have
each client independently train
its own model using its own
data right on the device.
No communication necessary.
Great idea, right?
Well, not quite because
each individual device
does not have enough data
to render a good model.
You could pre-train the model on
the server and then deploy it.
But the problem with that is,
in our smart keyboard example,
let's say if everyone started
using a new trendy word today,
then the model trained
on yesterday's data
won't be as useful.
So what should we do
to utilize the goodness
of decentralized data while
maintaining users' privacy?
Well, that's where
federated learning comes in.
The core idea behind
federated learning
is decentralized learning,
where the user data is never
sent to a central server.
So how does it work?
Well, you start with
a model on the server,
distribute it to the clients.
But you can't just
deploy to every client
because you don't want to
break the user experience.
You will identify
these clients based
on which ones are available,
plugged in, and not in use.
Then, also find
out which ones are
suitable because not all clients
will have the sufficient data.
Once you've identified
suitable devices,
we can then deploy
the model to them.
Now, each client trains
the model locally using
its own local data and
produces a new model,
which is sent to the server.
The thing to know here
is that the data used
to train the model on
the individual device
never leaves the device.
Only the weights, biases,
and other parameters
learned by the model
leave the device.
The server then
gets all the locally
trained models and
averages them out,
effectively creating
a new master model.
But how do we know
that this process
is doing something meaningful
and actually creating
a good model?
Doing this once is not enough.
We have to do it over and over
so the combined model becomes
the initial model
for the next round.
And with every round,
the combined model
gets a little bit better
thanks on the data
from all those clients.
And many, many rounds
later, your smart keyboard
begins to show signs
of intelligence.
Now, we just saw that all
the training data remains
on your device and
no individual updates
are stored in the cloud.
For additional privacy
in federated learning,
we can use the concept of
secure aggregation, where
the server pairs up devices
with others in a buddy system.
For example, here, each
device has two buddies.
Data from each device can be
combined with the random values
before being sent to the server.
The server obviously knows
the value sent to the buddies
and cancels them out to
just get the payload.
This trick obfuscates the data
while in transit to the server.
If you've used Google
Keyboard, the Gboard, then you
have already seen
and experienced
a federated learning use case.
The Gboard shows
a suggested query,
your phone locally
stores information
about the current
context and whether you
clicked the suggestion.
Federated learning processes
that history on device
to suggest improvements to
the next iteration of Gboard's
query suggestion model.
In this episode, we learned
that federated learning
is a collaborative and
decentralized approach
to machine learning that allows
for smarter models, lower
latency, and less
power consumption,
all while ensuring user privacy.
Federated learning is still
a relatively new concept,
and there's definitely
more to come in the future.
I would love to know some of
the federated learning use cases
that you're thinking about.
Drop them in the comments below.
And I look forward to seeing
you on the next episode of AI
Adventures.
In the meantime, if
you've enjoyed this video,
click that Like button and
subscribe to get all the latest
episodes right when they come.